[Musica]
Ma perché uno si mette a studiare il
cambiamento climatico Io sono 15 anni
non ho una risposta a questo
sto soltanto che non si comincia dalle
cose sexy dal grande riscaldamento
globale dagli eventi estremi si comincia
copiando sul computer uno dopo l'altro
numeri su numeri su numeri una cosa
alienante che si trovano in quegli
libroni polverosi che si chiamano annali
meteorologici gli annali meteorologici
hanno registrato per secoli temperature
precipitazioni pressioni
perché il cambiamento climatico il
riscaldamento globale non sono una
scuola di pensiero non sono una presa di
posizione politica non sono un modello
sono una realtà tangibile misurata e
misurabile basata su milioni di dati
pensate che l'Italia possiede le serie
meteorologiche termometriche in
particolare più antiche del mondo la
rete dei medici e del
1654 E nell'immagine vedete la cartina
del nostro paese con indicate le
stazioni meteorologiche secolari Che
tuttora l'istituto di scienze per
l'atmosfera era il clima del consiglio
nazionale delle ricerche utilizza quando
si parla di cambiamento climatico in
Italia
abbiamo milioni di dati che vanno tutti
nella stessa direzione il riscaldamento
globale in tutte le stagioni delle
temperature minime media e massime non
facciamo più finta di non saperlo grazie
Ma è successo qualcosa alla terra Com'è
andata la vostra estate che è durata
fino a oggi pomeriggio direi No
ma a me hanno detto che il sole non mi
hanno detto che sono i cicli dell'orbita
No forse sono i vulcani magari
climatologi non hanno le idee molto
chiare lo fanno soltanto per vendere
auto elettriche pannelli solari poi non
li sappiamo Come riciclare la
climatologia è una scienza nella sua
infanzia Assolutamente no questa donna
si chiama Unes Newton Food lei scrive un
articoletto nel
1856 perché fece un esperimento semplice
ma rivoluzionario prese due tubi uno
riempito d'aria l'altro riempito di
anidride carbonica li mise al sole Li
ritirò all'ombra e si accorse che quello
pieno di anidride carbonica era più
caldo e rilasciava il calore più
lentamente e scrive una frase in un
piccolo articolo che dice immaginate
soltanto una terra con più anidride
carbonica di così sarebbe sicuramente
più calda
1856 manda l'articolo all'American
Association for di advancement of
Science in una famosa riunione del 1000
dell'agosto di quell'anno non poter
leggerlo lei Perché per carità di Dio
facciamo mica leggere una donna e lei
venne ignorata lei venne ignorata la
madre del riscaldamento globale lei la
signora noi non facciamo più finta di
non saperlo
perché di clima si parla da quando
esiste la storia umana In Mesopotamia si
trovano tavolette che per circa 600 anni
consecutivi registrano le precipitazioni
e i venti perché lo facevano i
mesopotamici per trarre profezie sul
destino di un re oppure di un regno
salvo poi cambiare la profezia quando
quello che avveniva Non era esattamente
quello che avevano predetto ma in
mesopotamici fanno due cose
importantissime guardano la regolarità
del ripetersi dei fenomeni il clima e
guardano la variazione rispetto alla
regolarità e non erano mica i soli in
Cina dal circa mille anni avanti Cristo
vengono
inventati i primi strumenti
meteorologici in particolare i
pluviometri e gli igrometri gli
igrometri che registrano registrano
l'umidità servivano fare le prime
previsioni del tempo ai cinesi serviva
per un armonico controllo dello Stato
quel signore lì il primo che vedete si
chiama Ippocrate e il padre della
medicina lui nel IV secolo avanti Cristo
scrive un trattato sulle arie sulle
acque e sui luoghi nel quale dice la
prima cosa che va considerata quando si
parla della salute dell'umanità è il
clima del luogo in cui quella
popolazione vive la prima cosa perché il
clima determina l'uomo la sua salute e
la sua attitudine e quell'altro signore
è un certo Lucio anneo Seneca scrive le
nelle sue naturalis questiones che
esiste un equilibrio ambientale che lui
chiama equita sporzionum e questa
equitazione non può essere turbata
indovinate un po' da chi dalla specie
umana e lui Punta il dito sulla prima
delle attività tra virgolette
industriali la metallurgia l'estrazione
dei metalli che confonde insieme acqua e
terra non avevano le equazioni e i tempi
Ma cominciavano già a ragionare
dell'uomo che cambia il clima
non facciamo più finta di non saperlo
dal Medioevo fino al Settecento
succedono cose divertentissime la terra
Viene divisa in 7 clini potete
immaginare da Tolomeo in poi e ad ogni
clima appunto il clima determina
l'umanità viene assegnata Insomma
latitudine la salute di determinate
popolazioni o tutte le popolazioni si
arrogano di avere il clima migliore in
mezzo vedete il canone di avicenna
yvesna persiano il quale dice il clima
migliore ce l'hanno le zone Mediterranee
dove stanno i califfati e islamici e
Tant'è vero che le popolazioni
germaniche slave sono malinconiche in
acidite così come lo è il loro clima
qualche secolo dopo si vendicherà
Vladimir coupen che dirà no no no no le
civiltà migliori seguono il freddo Tanto
è vero che adesso la Germania è al
centro di tutto L'unica cosa che qui non
si spiega e lo scrive nel suo articolo E
come mai l'Italia sia sempre al centro
della cultura proprio non ce la fa
capire bontà sua quell'altro signore si
chiama Giuda Halley è un ebreo sefardita
al quale dice Ma cosa dici a vicenda La
Terra di Israele al centro dei climi al
centro del mondo Noi abbiamo il clima e
la cultura migliore questa idea porta
con sé quella che si chiama clina
climatologia colonialista Perché Che
inglesi francesi e olandesi si pongono
l'obiettivo di andare negli altri
continenti non soltanto a cambiargli le
culture ma cambiargli il clima perché se
cambio il clima di quei luoghi li rendo
meno selvaggi di quello che sono la
prima cosa che vogliono fare è tagliare
le foreste importano le colture europee
si aspettano che cambi il clima e a un
certo punto i maori e gli Abo mi dicono
agli olandesi e agli inglesi Guarda che
dovresti ascoltare noi queste cose non
funzionano quei No no che cosa ne vuoi
sapere tu Selvaggio e ovviamente avevano
ragione i maori e gli aborigeni
ancora si parlava di uomo che cambia il
clima Addirittura coi tempi l'uomo deve
cambiare il clima in particolare gli
europei devono cambiare il clima degli
altri continenti comincia a entrare
sempre di più questo concetto e quindi
non facciamo più finta di non saperlo
perché poi arrivano le equazioni ne
arrivano tantissime di equazioni lineari
non lineari vorticose turbolente tutte
quelle che volete
1822 comincia furie con la sua teoria
analitica del calore che vuole trovare
una grande legge Geofisica per il moto
delle acque dell'aria per l'evolversi
delle stagioni
dimostrabile in laboratorio espressa nel
calcolo differenziale quell'altro
signore baffuto si chiama svante al
renius lui nel 1896 scrive un articolo
importantissimo sull'influenza
dell'anidride carbonica in aria sulle
temperature al suolo
1896 la rivoluzione industriale c'è già
stata da un po' l'uomo emette Gas clima
alteranti in particolare l'anidride
carbonica della unis Food e a Renis dice
bene così perché io sono svedese e
voglio che in Scandinavia ci sia un
clima più equo
pensate come la pensavano e un altro
Quel signore che vedete sotto l'ombrello
si chiama Villa El viernes e norvegese
pure lui agli interessato al cambiamento
climatico al riscaldamento globale e lui
scrive 7 equazioni dinamiche
termodinamiche che secondo lui
dovrebbero permettere di fare le
previsioni del tempo dal da oggi
all'eternità nel 1963 arriva Edward
Norton Lorenz che ci dice c'è una cosa
che si chiama legge del caos effetto
farfalla Grazie di Ernest Ma questa cosa
è troppo importante la fisica la
matematica la chimica la geologia la
glociologia nell'Ottocento riempiono il
cambiamento climatico di equazioni nel
1956 Quegli ultimi due signori che
vedete revelle su essa giungono l'ultimo
tassello non solo l'atmosfera si sta
riempiendo di anidride carbonica di
origine umana si stanno riempiendo anche
gli oceani e loro dicono l'umanità sta
facendo un gigantesco esperimento
Geofisico del quale non avrà
giallo attenzione
la climatologia non è una scienza
giovane Gli scienziati sanno quello che
dicono e quindi non facciamo più finta
di non saperlo
e qui che avviene la rivoluzione
copernicana nella climatologia dal clima
che determinava l'uomo all'uomo che
determina il clima e allora ci viene
voglia di modellizzarlo questo clima di
creare dei modelli matematici sempre più
complessi che possono dirci come andrà a
finire sono su questi modelli che
ragionano i pianificatori agli
scienziati per il futuro dell'umanità i
modelli cominciano negli anni 50 si
perfezionano nel 60 e nel 70 prima con
noiman poi rospi poi quei tre signori lì
hasselman manabe e Parisi i quali hanno
preso un premio Nobel per la fisica nel
2021 per aver creato dei modelli
climatici talmente buoni che hanno
riprodotto correttamente il
riscaldamento globale di origine umana
Anzi sono stati fin troppo ottimisti lo
hanno sottostimato
e quindi lo vogliamo dire assieme non
facciamo più finta di non saperlo per
favore
cosa sta succedendo adesso
tre immagini per riempirvi di ottimismo
le precipitazioni estreme nelle Marche
il tragico distacco glaciale della
Marmolada l'uragano Ian in Florida dal
in seno alle Nazioni Unite nasce il
pannello intergovernativo sul
cambiamento climatico che organizza le
conferenze delle parti Le Coop le ultime
Cope sono state particolarmente positive
dalla Coop 21 alla Coop 26
e hanno chiesto all'umanità prendendosi
degli impegni scritti di limitare il
riscaldamento globale a un grado e mezzo
rispetto ai livelli pre-industriali e se
proprio proprio non ce la facciamo a due
sulla carta sono impegni molto buoni che
chiaramente non stiamo rispettando ma
sulla carta sono buoni
perché il sistema climatico è un sistema
complesso e purtroppo la variabile
principale adesso del sistema climatico
è l'umanità e l'umanità ad esempio
Quest'anno ho deciso che era ora di fare
una nuova guerra imperialista
colonialista fratricida che ci ha
riportato alla fame di combustibili
fossili alla fame di terra all'odio e
alla morte in un bellissimo libro di
fantascienza stanislav Lem Solaris
scrive laddove non esistono umani non
esistono motivazioni accessibili agli
umani dovremmo noi ricordarci di essere
umani per arrivare lì insieme
è davvero non facciamo più finta di non
saperlo Grazie